This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I'm sorry to do this, but I'm gonna take you back to January 6th, 2021. I can see at least half a dozen protesters scaling, literally climbing. A violent mob of Trump supporters attempted to overturn the 2020 election results with physical force. They broke into the Capitol, disrupted the Electoral college vote, and occupied the building for hours. Like most of you, I had my butt clenched that day, watching the insurrection unfold on television.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。非常抱歉，但我得把大家带回2021年1月6日。我能看到至少有六名抗议者在攀爬，字面意义上的攀爬。一群暴力的特朗普支持者试图用武力推翻2020年的选举结果。他们冲进国会大厦，打断了选举人团的投票，并在大楼里占据了数小时。和你们大多数人一样，那天我看着国会山骚乱在电视上实况转播，心里也是捏了一把汗。
Producer Vivian Le. I also happen to be watching that news coverage with my mom. I see every general, I watch ABC, I watch CBS, I watched CNN, I watched Fox, every, every perspective. This is my mom by the way. Do you want to say hi to my boss, Romas? Vinnie. Roman.
制作人维维安·勒。我当时恰好也和妈妈一起在看新闻报道。我看到了所有的将军，我看了ABC、CBS、CNN、福克斯，每一个，每一个视角。顺便说一下，这是我妈妈。你想跟我的老板罗曼打个招呼吗？维尼。罗曼。
Hi, Roman. It is Evian's mom. Hey mom. So that date during the insurrection, yes, we were both horrified, and yes, we were both worried about the state of democracy. But as my mom and I scanned the aerial shots of the riders marching down Pennsylvania Avenue, we also couldn't help but notice the dizzying amount of different types of flags there that day.
嗨，罗曼。我是埃维安的妈妈。嘿，妈妈。所以在骚乱发生的那天，是的，我们两个都感到震惊，是的，我们两个都为民主的现状感到担忧。但是，当我和妈妈浏览示威者沿着宾夕法尼亚大道游行的航拍画面时，我们也不禁注意到，那天那里出现的花样繁多的旗帜多得令人眼花缭乱。
Aside from seeing the obvious choices like the US or MAGA flag, there were some that were just really hideous graphic designs, like the flag of Trump photoshopped as Rambo, or Kelvin from Kelvin and Hobbs peeing on Biden. Still with just seemingly, you know, not attract me. They don't attract me either, Muff. Then there were the flags that even for a person like me who spends a lot of time thinking about flags couldn't decode. Yeah, I don't understand what got to stand for some flag, you know, what is it for some for row boys, some for white super supremacy?
除了美国国旗或“让美国再次伟大”（MAGA）旗帜等显而易见的选择外，还有一些旗帜的平面设计简直丑陋不堪，比如把特朗普P成兰博的旗帜，或者《卡尔文和霍布斯》里的卡尔文在拜登身上小便的旗帜。而且它们看起来，你知道的，并不吸引人。它们也不吸引我，Muff。然后还有一些旗帜，即使对我这种花大量时间研究旗帜的人来说也无法解读。是的，我搞不懂有些旗帜代表什么，你知道的，有些是给什么人准备的，有些是为了白人至上吗？
Yeah, super messy, but I don't know what to stand for because I'm not not on here. But flying from the balcony of the Capitol building along some of these inscrutable symbols was a flag that my mom instantly recognized. Actually, she more than just recognized it. Ha! That one! That's the one that we love, we cherish, our my life. It was such a simple design that most people probably didn't even notice it.
是的，极其混乱，但我不知道它代表什么，因为我不是——我没去那儿。但是，在国会大厦阳台上飘扬的、伴随着这些晦涩符号的旗帜中，有一面我妈妈一眼就认出来了。实际上，她不仅仅是认出来。哈！那面！那就是我们深爱的、珍惜的、甚至视如我们一命的旗帜。它的设计非常简单，以至于大多数人可能根本没有注意到它。
Bright yellow with three red horizontal stripes across the center. This was the flag of South Vietnam. This is the flag that she grew up with. It reminds her of some of the best years of her life. So when she saw it flying alongside banners that overtly signaled hate, racism and misogyny that day, it felt like it was telling the rest of the world that hate. This flag stands for all those things too. It feels shame because of people raising it at the wrong day, the wrong event.
亮黄色底，正中有三道红色横条。这就是南越国旗。这是她伴随着长大的旗帜。它让她想起她一生中最美好的几年。所以当她看到这面旗帜在当那天公然标志着仇恨、种族主义和厌女症的横幅旁飘扬时，感觉就像是在向全世界宣告仇恨。这面旗帜也代表着所有这些东西。因为人们在错误的日子、错误的活动中举起它，她感到羞耻。
The flag of South Vietnam and what it should stand for is a really contentious issue for the Vietnamese American community. And while seeing it raise it, the insurrection felt like the wrong way to use this flag for my mom, the right way to use it was I'd love to make a thing about this one a little bit. Because it's a little bit serious. You know? So I have to think something that I... Just say...
南越国旗及其所代表的含义，对美籍越南人社群来说是一个极具争议的问题。虽然看到它在骚乱中被举起，对妈妈来说觉得是这面旗帜的错误用法，但正确的用法是……我挺想就这个做点东西的。因为这稍微有点严肃。你知道吗？所以我得想点……就说……
If I were to ask you to draw the Vietnamese flag and that's all I specified, which one would you draw? That's a good one. I don't know if I can do that. I guess, you know, like any academic, right? I would say, like, give me more information. This is Tuan Huang. He's a historian and associate professor at Pepperdine University
如果我让你画一面越南国旗，而且我只作了这一项要求，你会画哪一面？这是一个好问题。我不知道我能不能做到。我想，你知道的，就像任何学者一样，对吧？我会说，比如，请给我更多信息。这是段黄（Tuan Huang）。他是一位历史学家，也是佩珀代因大学的副教授。
who did not fall for my got to journalism. A lot like myself, he didn't think to explore the history of the flag until fairly recently. I mean, I did not plan it all to look into the history of the Savviness flag. And then like January 6th happened and then boom, he's just like, oh my god, I need to look into this. There were actually several confounding international flags present at the Capitol riot that day. The Canadian, Indian and South Korean flags were all spotted somewhere in the mayhem. But what was peculiar about the Vietnamese flag being there is that it's not technically the flag of Vietnam. It's the flag of the Republic of Vietnam, a country that no longer exists.
他并没有掉进我设下的“钓鱼式”新闻采访的陷阱。和我很像，直到不久前他才开始探索这面旗帜的历史。我的意思是，我根本没打算去研究南越旗帜的历史。然后1月6日事件发生了，接着“轰”的一声，他心想，哦天哪，我得研究一下这个。那天在国会骚乱现场，其实出现了好几个让人摸不着头头的国际旗帜。加拿大、印度和韩国国旗都在这场混乱的某个地方被发现了。但越南国旗出现在那里的奇怪之处在于，它严格来说并不是越南的国旗。它是越南共和国的国旗，这是一个已经不复存在的国家。
The Republic of Vietnam, or more commonly known as South Vietnam, was in a way a reaction to a reaction to colonialism, because the country has spent over a thousand years being ruled by outside forces. Colonialism was massively important in the history of Vietnam. Vietnam spent much of its early history ruled by China, and then in the mid-1800s Vietnam came under the control of outside powers again, this time France. We spent a lot of time dragging British colonialism on the show, but today we're coming for the French. For decades, France exploited Vietnam's natural resources, made the poor more poor, and suppressed Vietnamese identity,
越南共和国，更为人所知的是南越，在某种程度上是对殖民地主义的一种反弹，因为这个国家曾有一千多年时间被外部势力统治。殖民主义在越南历史上极其重要。越南早期历史的大部分时间都受中国统治，然后在19世纪中期，越南再次受到外部势力的控制，这次是法国。我们在节目里花了很多时间痛斥英国殖民地主义，但今天我们要对付法国了。几十年来，法国剥削越南的自然资源，让穷人更穷，并压制越南人的身份认同，
even banning the word Vietnam from the region because it was associated with self-determination. The Vietnamese, right, they hated it. They did not want to be ruled by French in this case. Another big consequence of colonialism was that it led different Vietnamese people into two clashing political ideologies. Some groups were leaning towards reform. Some groups were leaning towards more radical
甚至在当地禁止使用“越南”这个词，因为它与自决权联系在一起。越南人，没错，他们对此深恶痛绝。在这种情况下，他们绝对不想被法国人统治。殖民主义带来的另一个重大后果是，它导致不同的越南人走向了两种截然不同的政治意识形态。一些群体倾向于改良。一些群体则倾向于更激进的
ideology like communism. There were those who believed that, yes, colonialism is bad, but also wanted to stay closely aligned with the United States. But leaders like Ho Chi Minh in the North believed that there would be no flourishing under any form of imperialism. Vietnam needed to be a completely independent
意识形态，比如共产主义。有些人认为，是的，殖民主义是坏事，但也希望与美国保持紧密的同盟关系。但北方的领导人如胡志明则认为，在任何形式的帝国主义下都不会有繁荣。越南必须是一个完全独立且共产主义的国家。
and communist state. Ho Chi Minh and his army, the Vietnam, defeated the French in 1954, which rattled the Western world. Countries like the US were concerned that communism would continue spreading throughout Southeast Asia. The Palais de Nassong, where the League of Nations wrestled with international problems many years ago now, is the handsome setting for the Geneva Conference. Korea and Indochina are the chief problems to be solved.
胡志明和他的军队，即越南独立同盟会，在1954年击败了法国，这让西方世界感到震惊。像美国这样的国家担心共产主义会继续在东南亚蔓延。纳松宫（Palais de Nassong）是多年前国际联盟处理国际问题的地方，如今它是日内瓦会议的美丽举办地。朝鲜和印度支那成为亟待解决的主要问题。
During the 1954 Geneva Conference, it was decided that France would withdraw from northern Vietnam. It was also decided that until free elections could be held, the country would be split in two. Vietnam was partitioned at the 17th parallel, with a communist country in the north and in the south, a country that was nominally democratic with a heavy U.S. influence. Two separate ideologies, territories, and flags. The flag of South Vietnam was a yellow field
在1954年的日内瓦会议期间，各方决定法国将从越南北部撤军。同时决定，在举行自由选举之前，该国将被一分为二。越南在北纬17度线被分割，北方是一个共产主义国家，南方则是一个受美国深刻影响的名义上的民主国家。两种截然不同的意识形态、领土和国旗。南越的国旗是一片黄色的旗地，正中有三道细长的红色横条平行贯穿。
with three thin red stripes running horizontally across the center. The yellow symbolized the people and the three red stripes represented the three distinct regions of the country. North, central, and South Vietnam unified under one banner. In the North leadership wanted the same thing. A unified Vietnam under these same two colors,
黄色象征着人民，三道红条代表着该国的三个不同地区。北部、中部和南部越南统一在同一面旗帜下。北方的领导层也想要同样的东西。在一个统一的越南下使用这同样的两种颜色，
but theirs was a different flag, a red field with a bright yellow star at the center. The five points of the star were to represent peasants, workers, intellectuals, traders, and soldiers who unite to build socialism. These two Vietnam clashed in a civil war that lasted for two decades. The US wanted South Vietnam to be its anti-communist stronghold in Southeast Asia. But as the war dragged on, it became clearer and clearer that a democratic Vietnam was not possible. And so long story short, right? By 1973, the US troops have withdrawn pretty much completely.
但他们的国旗不同，是一片红色的旗地，正中有一颗亮黄色的星星。五角分别代表农民、工人、知识分子、商人和士兵，他们团结起来建设社会主义。这两个越南在一场持续了二十年的内战中发生冲突。美国希望南越成为其在东南亚的反共据点。但随着战争的拖延，越来越明显的是，一个民主的越南是不可能的。所以长话短说，对吧？到1973年，美军几乎已经完全撤离了。
They just, you know, don't want to deal with that word anymore. Here's my mom again. She actually lived in Saigon and was in law school during this time. They decided, you know, like with your from the country and then, you know, we know that we will, you know, lose your fight with Communists. If South Vietnam fell, anyone associated with the US government or South Vietnamese military could be a target for the North Vietnamese regime. My mom had family in the military and also a sister who worked for the Americans, so it wouldn't be safe to stay. But because of these connections, she was able to flee right before the city was captured. We just packed up some little thing, you know, personal thing and go. And I remember I only carry a small stuff like personal, like a love letter, a memory book from high school, and feel close.
他们只是，你知道的，再也不想处理那个烂摊子了。这是我妈妈。她当时确实住在西贡，并在那期间读法学院。他们决定，你知道的，既然你的国家完了，然后，你知道的，我们知道你会，你知道的，输掉与共产党的这场仗。如果南越沦陷，任何与美国政府或南越军队有联系的人都可能成为北越政权的目标。我妈妈家里有人当兵，还有一个姐姐为美国人工作，所以留下来并不安全。但由于这些关系，她得以在城市被攻陷前夕逃离。我们只是打包了一些小东西，你知道的，个人物品然后就走了。我记得我只带了一些小东西，比如个人物品，像情书、高中毕业纪念册，感觉很亲近。
And that's it. Just the backpack, you know, nothing else. My mom was a lot more privileged and a hell of a lot luckier than most people in South Vietnam. And she still lost everything. Oh, I'm crying when the flight leaves off. And I see the land, you know, down there. And my tears just kept my eye on it a lot. I know that, you know, down there. And it might just kept my hour a lot. I know that, you know, I never see it again. She was actually on one of the last planes
就这样。只有一个背包，你知道的，没有别的了。我妈妈比南越大多数人享有更多的特权，也幸运得多。但她还是失去了所有东西。哦，当飞机起飞时我在哭。我看着陆地，你知道的，在下面。我的眼泪一直止不住地流。我知道，你知道的，在下面。我的眼泪一直止不住地流。我知道，你知道的，我再也见不到它了。她其实是最后一批离开该国的飞机之一。
to leave the country. The next day, the airport was bombed. A few days later, North Vietnamese tanks crashed through the gates of the presidential palace since I got and took down the flag of South Vietnam. The war was over. The conquering tanks burst straight into the presidential palace.
第二天，机场就被轰炸了。几天后，北越的坦克冲破了西贡总统府的大门，扯下了南越国旗。战争结束了。征服者的坦克直接冲进了总统府。
For the fourth time in a month, the presidential palace had new occupants, but these had come to stay. The war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, war, 1975, that's the day when South Vietnam fell to the North Vietnamese. This is Tui Vau Dang, curator of UC Irvine's Southeast Asian archive. In Vietnam, it's known as Liberation Day, and in the diaspora, it's often referred to as Nay Makhna, or the day we lost our homeland, right, or Nygokhton, or the day of national resentment. After the fall of Saigon, the North and South once again became one nation. The new government of the Socialist Republic of Vietnam immediately went to task undoing
一个月内的第四次，总统府迎来了新的主人，但这些新人是来长住的。1975年，那是南越向北越沦陷的日子。这是加州大学欧文分校东南亚档案馆馆长杜·武·当（Tuu Vu Dang）。在越南，这被称为“解放日”；而在海外侨民中，它通常被称为“Nay Makhna”，即我们失去家园的日子，没错，或者被称为“Nygokhton”，即国恨日。西贡沦陷后，南北方再次成为一个国家。越南社会主义共和国的新政府立即着手消除
years of capitalist influence on the southern half of the country. And so they embark on a number of measures. You know, that effected all of Vietnam, but especially some Vietnamese, right, this, this, this vision of establishing a socialist paradise, so to speak. This included changing the currency of Vietnam to undercut the wealthy elites and forcibly relocating roughly a million southerners. But the most infamous post-war policy was incarcerating former South Vietnamese military officers, religious leaders, journalists, academics, artists, basically anyone who didn't agree with the North Vietnamese government in re-education camps.
多年来资本主义对该国南部的影响。于是他们着手采取了一系列措施。你知道的，这些措施影响了整个越南，但特别是南越人，对吧，这种——这种建立所谓社会主义天堂的愿景。这包括更改越南货币以打击富裕精英，并将大约一百万南方人强行迁往他处。但战后最臭名昭著的政策是将前南越军官、宗教领袖、记者、学者、艺术家，基本上所有不同意北越政府的人，关进再教育营。
For they spent years starving and forced in a manual labor. After the country re-unified, South Vietnam didn't just lose its political recognition and its spot on the map, it was actively erased. The government confiscated records, cassette tapes, right, of music produced, you know, in South Vietnam. They confiscated, you know, hundreds of thousands of books in magazines that were published in South Vietnam. You know, and many of them were burned. So when the first wave of South Vietnamese refugees settled in other parts of the world in the late 70s and early 80s, that music, history, and culture became the responsibility
他们在那里度过了多年的饥饿生活并被迫进行体力劳动。国家重新统一后，南越不仅失去了其政治上的承认和在地图上的位置，它还被积极地抹去了。政府没收了在南越制作的音乐的记录、磁带，对吧。他们没收了在南越出版的数以百计的图书和杂志。你知道的，其中许多都被烧毁了。因此，当第一批南越难民在70年代末和80年代初在世界其他地方定居时，这些音乐、历史和文化就成了
of the diaspora. Which is why the flag is so important to people like my mom. We cherish that flag, it's the day that we flag the country and we don't have the land anymore. We just have the flag. Tuan Wang says that for a lot of early Vietnamese-American refugees, the yellow flag with red stripes stands for more than an allegiance to a non-existent country. It also represents a different, less commonly told perspective on the Vietnam War. There are enough history books and documentaries on the subject to keep any retired dad occupied for years.
海外侨民的责任。这就是为什么这面旗帜对像我妈妈这样的人来说如此重要。我们珍惜这面旗帜，这是我们为国家降半旗的日子，我们不再拥有那片土地。我们只剩下这面旗帜。段黄说，对于许多早期的越南裔美国难民来说，带有红条的黄旗不仅仅代表对一个不复存在的国家的忠诚。它还代表了关于越南战争的一种不同的、不常被讲述的视角。关于这个主题的历史书和纪录片多得足以让任何退休老爸忙上好几年。
But these were all about America's role in the war. America's mistakes. America's loss. Even the most visible monument to the war, the Vietnam Veterans Memorial in DC was a tribute to the US service members. But really, really, really, there was hardly anything that represents the South Vietnamese experience. The South Vietnamese flag did that. For the generation that fled the country, it became a banner, a memorial, and a link connecting the South Vietnamese scattered all around the world.
但这些全都聚焦于美国在战争中的角色。美国的错误。美国的失败。甚至连战争中最显眼的纪念碑——华盛顿特区的越南退伍军人纪念碑，也是为了向美国军人致敬。但实际上，真的，真的，几乎没有任何东西能够代表南越人的经历。南越国旗做到了这一点。对于逃离该国的那一代人来说，它成了一个标语、一座纪念碑，也是将散落在世界各地的南越人连接在一起的纽带。
As the US rekindled diplomatic relations with Vietnam in the late 80s and 90s, a new wave of migration took place to the west. Many of those South Vietnamese had been political prisoners after the fall of Saigon. So to them, seeing this flag flying broad took on new meaning that wasn't just about nostalgia. The experience of Vietnamese, right, who were living difficult lives in Vietnam after the war, right? And then who eventually came to the US, and you know, Canada, so on, right?
随着美国在80年代末和90年代与越南重新建立外交关系，新一波的移民潮向西方涌去。许多南越人在西贡沦陷后曾是政治犯。因此对他们来说，看到这面旗帜在海外飘扬被赋予了新的含义，而不仅仅是关于乡愁。越南人的经历，对吧，他们在战后在越南过着艰难的生活，对吧？然后他们最终来到美国，你知道的，加拿大，诸如此类，对吧？
The experience is a symbol of freedom, you know, post-war freedom. Municipalities all over the world actually fly the South Vietnamese flag out of respect for local Vietnamese communities. And it has been reclassified as the freedom-inherited flag in a number of cities across the country. If you spend enough time in a Vietnamese enclave, you might end up thinking that this was the official flag of Vietnam. I 100% grew up thinking that. I actually remember the day that I found out Vietnam's official flag was something different. I was in sixth grade, and our social studies class was assigned a project.
这种经历是自由的象征，你知道的，战后的自由。世界各地的城市实际上都在悬挂南越国旗，以表达对当地越南社群的尊重。它在全美许多城市被重新归类为“自由传承旗”。如果你在越南人聚居区呆的时间够久，你可能会以为这就是越南的官方旗帜。我百分之百是在这种认知下长大的。我其实还记得我发现越南官方旗帜其实是别的样子的那一天。我当时上六年级，我们的社会科老师布置了一个项目。
It was something that you've probably had to do at some point in grade school. It was a country report. You choose a nation, and then compile a bunch of data, tuck it into a neat little binder, and then present it to the rest of your class. Being Vietnamese American, and also wanting to put in as little effort as possible, I naturally chose Vietnam. But part of the assignment was to draw a picture of that nation's flag, so I booted up in Cardin 95, a program that I was using well into the year 2001, and used some colored
那是你可能在小学某个阶段也做过的事情。那是一个国家报告。你选择一个国家，然后收集一堆数据，把它塞进一个整洁的小文件夹里，然后向全班同学做展示。身为越南裔美国人，同时又想尽量少花点力气，我自然选择了越南。但作业的一部分是画出那个国家的国旗，所以我打开了“画图”（Cardin 95）——这个程序我一直用到2001年还在用——并用一些彩色铅笔把我在《奥西塔》报纸上看到的图形临摹了下来。
pencils to transpose the graphic that I saw on the Oshita paper. It was a red field, with a bright yellow 5-pointed star at the center. I didn't recognize this flag, but who was I to question in Cardin 95? The morning my project was due, my dad was horrified at the sight of that 5-pointed star on my homework. And that reaction is pretty common among South Vietnamese refugees. You would never want to show that, Vlad. People will really throw things at you. A lot of refugees see the official flag,
那是一片红色的旗地，正中有一颗亮黄色的五角星。我不认识这面国旗，但我怎么能质疑“画图”95呢？交作业那天早上，我爸爸看到我作业上的那颗五角星时吓坏了。这种反应在南越难民中相当普遍。你永远不会想展示那个，弗拉德。人们真的会朝你扔东西。许多难民把官方国旗——
the red flag with the yellow 5.0 star, as a reminder of what they'd fled in Vietnam. So as Vietnamese Americans became more politically active in the 90s and early 2000s, essentially anywhere the official flag appeared, a protest would follow. They were a constant thing every weekend, you know, in Little Saigon. There was a protest that was somehow related to the flag. The biggest incident happened in 1999, at a suburban strip mall right at the heart of Orange County's Little Saigon.
带有黄色五角星的红旗——视为他们在越南逃离的事物的提醒。因此，随着越南裔美国人在90年代和2000年代初变得更加积极地参与政治，基本上只要官方国旗出现的地方，抗议活动就会随之而来。它们是每个周末都会发生的事情，你知道的，在小西贡。总会有一场多多少少与这面旗帜有关的抗议活动。最大的事件发生在1999年，地点在奥兰治县小西贡心脏地带的一个郊区购物中心。
Actually, just two blocks from where my parents worked. The scene was reminiscent of the 60s, row after row of police and full riot gear. Civil disobedience. The owner of a video store called High Tech TV and VCR was a recent immigrant from Vietnam, and he decided to put up the red flag along with a portrait of Ho Chi Minh. The owner in this case was kind of asking for trouble. Well, he was literally asking for trouble. The store owner actually sent facts messages to local Vietnamese community leaders, detailing what he had done and daring them to do something about it.
实际上，离我父母工作的地方只有两个街区。那场面让人想起60年代，一排又一排穿着防暴装备的警察。公民抗命。一家名为“高科技电视与录像机”（High Tech TV and VCR）的音像店老板是来自越南的新移民，他决定挂起红旗以及一幅胡志明的肖像。这位店老板在这种情况下简直是自找麻烦。好吧，他字面意义上就是在自找麻烦。这位店老板实际上向当地越南社群领袖发送了传真，详细说明了他所做的事情，并挑衅他们采取行动。
The protest lasted for months, and at its peak, the LA Times recorded over 15,000 protesters in one day. I used to get my hair cut in this plaza, and I cannot imagine that many people cramming into that little parking lot. No! No! No! No! Where's Haldirov? Tweebo Deng actually went to these protests back in 1999. And you can see that, yes, the official red star flag was capable of setting off a firestorm of controversy. But the yellow flag of South Vietnam could also be a polarizing symbol,
抗议活动持续了几个月，《洛杉矶时报》记录下在高峰期的一天内有超过15000名抗议者。我以前经常在这个广场理发，我无法想象那么多人能挤进那个小停车场里。不！不！不！不！阿尔迪罗夫在哪里？杜·武·当其实在1999年时也去参加了这些抗议活动。你可以看到，是的，官方的红星旗确实能够引发一场争议的风暴。但南越的黄旗也可能是一个两极分化的象征，
especially when you think about who is excluded and what kind of conversations are shut down by it. It is the only flag allowed in little flag on. So that is a certain kind of sanctioning as well, right? And how do people who have immigrated here very recently have grown up in Vietnam with the red flag only? How do they feel around the lunar new year when they walk around bolstaya venue and only see the yellow flag? The South Vietnamese flag could be especially inciting when used in community politics.
特别是当你考虑到谁被排除了，以及它压制了什么样的对话时。它是小西贡唯一允许悬挂的旗帜。所以这也是一种某种程度上的认可，对吧？那些最近才移民到这里、在越南只伴随着红旗长大的人，他们会作何感想？当他们在农历新年期间走在波尔斯特亚大道上，却只看到黄旗时，他们是什么心情？南越国旗在用于社群政治时尤其具有煽动性。
If the official five pointed star flag of Vietnam is viewed as the Communist flag, then the yellow flag with red stripes of South Vietnam is seen as the anti-communist flag. When you call someone a communist in the little site on community, that's like a death knell for their political career. It's land-dressed, it's like... So, I mean, I see that used in ways that have been intended to cause harm, right, to leverage the emotional weight that we've put to this flag, right, and try to hurt others. These staunch anti dichomingous views are actually a big part of why first generation Vietnamese Americans have always been a pretty reliable
如果越南官方的五角星旗被视为共产主义旗帜，那么南越带有红条的黄旗就被视为反共旗帜。在小西贡社群里称呼某人为共产党，这就像是对他们政治生涯的死刑宣告。这是土地打扮，这就像是……所以，我的意思是，我看到它被用于旨在造成伤害的方式，对吧，去利用我们赋予这面旗帜的情感分量，对吧，并试图伤害他人。这些坚定的反共观点实际上是第一代越南裔美国人一直是相当可靠的
Republican voting block. That and a lot of Vietnamese people also tend to be drawn to the GOP's hardline stance on China, which I don't agree with. But apparently a thousand years of occupation and territorial disputes can lead to a pretty gnarly grudge. That is something that we can actually generalize meaningfully. The easiest way to anger a Vietnamese is just say something nice about China.
共和党票仓的一个重要原因。再加上许多越南人也往往会被共和党对中国的强硬立场吸引，虽然我不同意这一点。但显然，长达千年的占领和领土争端可以积攒下相当棘手的积怨。这是我们可以做出有意义的普遍化推论的事情。激怒一个越南人的最简单方法就是说几句中国的好话。
The South Vietnamese flag has been drifting towards politically conservative symbolism for a while now. For some, the yellow flag with red stripes has become a shorthand for right-wing nationalism. It had been a constant presence at Trump rallies leading up to January 6th, so many of us in the community weren't even surprised to see it at the insurrection. I was disheartened. I was angry. I was frustrated, all of those things, but I wasn't surprised. There's a huge generational divide in the Vietnamese community when it comes to politics. So much so that there's even a support group on Facebook for Asian-Americans with Republican
南越国旗现在一直在向政治保守主义象征的方向漂移。对某些人来说，带红条的黄旗已经成了右翼民族主义的代名词。在导致1月6日的特朗普集会上，它一直是常客，所以我们社群里的许多人看到它出现在骚乱中甚至并不感到惊讶。我感到沮丧。我很愤怒。我很受挫，所有这些情绪都有，但我并不感到惊讶。越南社群在政治方面存在巨大的代沟。以至于甚至有一个面向有共和党父母的亚裔美国人的Facebook互助群，里面挤满了第二代越南裔小孩。
parents that's filled with second-generation Vietnamese kids. Like a lot of conservative America, Republican Vietnamese have been drawn to Trumpism. And for the older generation especially, the ones who experienced the war, there could still be a deep fear of communism. So when they hear stuff like this, like it or not, we are becoming a communist country. That's what's happening.
就像保守派美国的许多地方一样，共和党籍的越南人也被特朗普主义所吸引。特别是对于老一辈人，那些经历过战争的人来说，内心可能仍然对共产主义有着深深的恐惧。所以当他们听到这样的话时，比如“不管你喜欢与否，我们正在变成一个共产主义国家。这就是正在发生的事。”
That's what's happening. That pulls on actual lived trauma. The people who brought the South Vietnamese flag to the insurrection only represented a very small and very noisy subsect of the community. Most people, including my mom, hated seeing the flag there that day. That day, that January 6, right?
“这就是正在发生的事。”这触动了现实中经历过的创伤。把南越国旗带到骚乱现场的人只代表了该社群中极小且非常喧闹的一个亚群。大多数人，包括我妈妈，都不愿意在那天看到这面旗帜出现在那里。那一天，那个1月6日，对吧？
That's a lot of debate after that in the community. There's a lot of people against that people bring the flag to that event. And they too, I don't like it. In the days following January 6th, a number of write-ups were published to help people, quote, decode some of the racist imagery of the insurrection. And some of them included the South Vietnamese flag. I felt queasy seeing it lumped in with all these symbols of hate. For a large swath of the U.S., January 6 was probably the first time they'd even seen
在那之后，社群里进行了大量的辩论。有很多人反对人们把这面旗帜带到那场活动中去。他们也不喜欢，我也不喜欢。在1月6日之后的几天里，发表了许多文章来帮助人们，引述一下，“解码”骚乱的一些种族主义形象。其中一些文章甚至包含了南越国旗。看到它与所有这些仇恨象征混为一谈，我感到一阵恶心。对美国的大片民众来说，1月6日可能是他们第一次见到
the South Vietnamese flag. It is not far-fetched to think that some observers may have wondered what radical group this yellow flag with red stripes represented. The South Vietnamese flags presents that day, brought up a lot of questions for those of us who don't wanna see it end up like Pepe the frog. But Tui Vodang thinks that this doesn't just have to be an embarrassing moment
南越国旗。不难想象，一些观察家可能会好奇，这面带红条的黄旗代表了哪个激进组织。南越国旗在那天的出现，给我们这些不希望它最终变成像佩佩蛙（Pepe the frog）那样的人带来了很多疑问。但杜·武·当认为，这不应该仅仅是美籍越南人社群的一个尴尬时刻，
for the Vietnamese American community. It could also be an opportunity to face our history before it gets co-opted by any side of the political spectrum. It's up to us to do the work of pushing the conversation towards understanding the nuances and complexities of our history. But I think, you know, all of the attention that came after the appearance of the yellow flag at the insurrection could enable an entry point. I think a lot of people in my generation have a very different relationship to this flag and to Vietnam itself. To me, the flag just can't be boiled down to freedom, or nostalgia, or anti-communism,
它也可以是一个机会，让我们在历史被政治光谱的任何一方劫持之前正视我们的历史。我们有责任推动对话，去理解我们历史的细微差别和复杂性。但我认为，你知道的，黄旗在骚乱中出现后带来的所有关注，可以提供一个切入点。我认为我这一代人中的许多人与这面旗帜以及越南本身有着非常不同的关系。对我来说，这面旗帜不能简单地归结为自由、乡愁或反共，
or any of the other one-liners ascribed to it. It's a complex symbol for the complicated history of how I got here. When I just started my life here, I missed everything, you know, in the past, but now it's okay. I like it here. I hadn't really thought about it before, but my mom's life directly reflects the yellow flag with red stripes. She was born in 1955, the same year that South Vietnam was created. And she fled the country in 1975, the year it ended. I just spent 20 years on my life first life in Vietnam.
或者归结为贴在他身上的任何其他单行标语。对于我如何来到这里的复杂历史而言，它是一个复杂的象征。当我刚刚开始这里的生计时，我怀念一切，你知道的，过去的一切，但现在没事了。我喜欢这里。我以前从没认真想过这件事，但妈妈的人生直接呼应了这面带红条的黄旗。她出生于1955年，也就是南越建立的那一年。而她在1975年逃离了该国，也就是它结束的那一年。我刚刚在越南度过了我人生的前20年，第一段人生。
And now I'm 66. So more than the book here in the United States, so I love this country. My mom said something that stuck with me that I think applies to the flag of South Vietnam too. She doesn't want to live in the past, but she doesn't want to forget it either. She wants the same for me too. Because one day, the war will stop being a living memory and just be history. And what will be left with is a yellow flag with red stripes.
而现在我66岁了。所以在美国这里的时间比那边多得多，所以我爱这个国家。我妈妈说的话有一句深深触动了我，我认为这也适用于南越国旗。她不想活在过去，但她也不想忘记过去。她对我也抱有同样的期望。因为有一天，这场战争将不再是一段活生生的记忆，而仅仅成为历史。而留给我们的将是一面带红条的黄旗。
After the break, Vivian comes back to help so much for that story. I always love the stories where I learn a little bit more about you guys' lives. Yeah, and talk to your parents too. Exactly. So yeah, so this is actually going to be like the Vietnamese-iest episode ever because I'm going to talk about Faw restaurants. So if any listeners don't know what Faw is, I feel bad for you because it's so good. It's probably the most visible dish that has come out of Vietnam. Like when I meet someone and they find out I'm Vietnamese and they don't know
休息过后，维维安回来为这个故事提供更多帮助。我一直很喜欢那些能让我多了解一点你们生活的日子的故事。是的，也多跟你们的父母聊聊。没错。所以，是的，这实际上将是有史以来“最越南”的一集，因为我要谈论河粉（Pho）餐馆。所以如果有听众不知道什么是河粉，我为你感到难过，因为它太美味了。它可能是从越南走出来的最知名的菜肴。就像当我遇到某人，他们发现我是越南人，他们不知道
how to make conversational watch times something like, well, I like Faw. I'm like, okay, great. Thank you for that., like when I meet someone and they find out I'm Vietnamese and they don't know how to make conversational law to times something like, well, I like fun. I'm like, okay, great, thank you for that. But like I guess to boil it down to its most basic level, it's like a noodle plus protein plus fragrant broth soup and it has like bean sprouts and Thai basil and lime and onions. You're giving a kit when you get it.
如何进行闲聊时，有时会说类似“嗯，我喜欢河粉”。我会说，好吧，太棒了。谢谢你这么说。就像当我遇到某人，他们发现我是越南人，他们不知道如何进行闲聊时，有时会说类似“嗯，我喜欢河粉”。我会说，好吧，太棒了，谢谢你这么说。但就像我猜的，如果把它简化到最基本的层面，它就像是一份面条加蛋白质加芳香肉汤的汤面，里面还有豆芽、泰国罗勒、青柠和洋葱。当你点它的时候，你会拿到一个配料包。
It's like, it is really the greatest soup. And I know that that's a contentious subject when it comes to a lot of people and a lot of soups and different cultures, but I'm here to tell you, full as the best, as far as I'm right. It's the best soup. Yeah. The accoutrements alone that come with the bull of us. But, you know, if you drive through pretty much any little sagan in the world, you would
就像，它真的是最棒的汤。我知道当涉及许多人、许多汤和不同的文化时，这是一个有争议的话题，但我在这里告诉你们，河粉就是最好的，就河粉而言。它是最好的汤。是的。光是那一碗河粉自带的配菜就……但是，如果你开车穿过世界上几乎任何一个小西贡，你可能
probably notice that there's this really common naming convention when it comes to father restaurants. And I think it's really well articulated by Allie Wong in her comedy special, Baby Cobra. So Wong herself is Vietnamese. And there's this part where she's talking about how her now husband tried to take her to like a quote authentic Vietnamese restaurant on one of their first dates. He took me to this restaurant on the west side of Los Angeles called Faux Show. He was like, it's authentic Vietnamese. I read about it on Yelp.
会注意到，在河粉餐馆的命名方面，有一个非常常见的命名惯例。我想黄阿丽（Ali Wong）在她的喜剧专场《小眼镜蛇》（Baby Cobra）中对此做了非常精彩的阐述。黄阿丽本人就是越南人。其中有一段她谈到她的现任丈夫如何在他们的第一次约会之一时试图带她去一家所谓的“正宗越南餐馆”。他带我去了洛杉矶西区的一家名为“Pho Show”的餐馆。他说，这是正宗的越南菜。我在Yelp上看到的。
I was like, it's not authentic. Okay, you can tell first and foremost by the name because it don't got a number in it. So she's talking about this completely valid stereotype about Vietnamese restaurants that they're always named like the word fa plus a seemingly random number. Like right now I'm looking at a map of Orange County and there's a fun 99
我说，这不正宗。好吧，你首先可以通过名字看出来，因为它里面没有数字。所以她在谈论关于越南餐馆的一个完全成立的刻板印象，即它们总是命名为“Pho”这个词加上一个看似随机的数字。就像我现在正在看一张奥兰治县的地图，有一个“河粉99”（Pho 99）
right next to a Fah 86 which is less than a block away from a Fah 45 and then there's a Fah 54 around the corner from a Fah 79 which is very good by the way it's a great restaurant. So there's a very very common thing that you will see with Vietnamese restaurants that they always kind of include a number. So what's the number all about? Yeah, so sometimes the restaurant will have a number just because like the numbers themselves are lucky. Like if you see a Fav, 555 or a Fav, 888, it's because 5 and 8 are like auspicious numbers in a lot of Eastern cultures. Plus it's like super memorable to have like three numbers in a row. But if you pay close enough attention to the numbers, they can actually tell you about the restaurant's owners
紧挨着一个“河粉86”（Pho 86），而它离一个“河粉45”（Pho 45）不到一个街区，然后转角处还有一个“河粉54”（Pho 54），离“河粉79”（Pho 79）很近，顺便说一句，那家非常棒，是一家很棒的餐馆。所以你会看到越南餐馆有一个非常非常普遍的现象，那就是它们总是会包含一个数字。那么，这个数字究竟是怎么回事？是的，所以有时餐馆会有数字，纯粹是因为数字本身很吉利。就像如果你看到“河粉555”或“河粉888”，那是因为在许多东方文化中，5和8是吉祥数字。再加上一连三个相同的数字超级容易让人记住。但如果你足够仔细地关注这些数字，它们实际上可以告诉你餐馆老板的
family history or the history of Vietnam in general. So if you see a restaurant called like Fa 86 or Fa 79, that could represent that the owner of the restaurant immigrated from Vietnam in 1986 or in 1979. So that's a really common naming convention of Vietnamese American culture. And it's this way to kind of pay tribute to the start of this new life. Yeah, like around our office in Oakland, we have a 584, which I like to visit. So my guess is 84 makes it
家庭历史或越南的整体历史。所以如果你看到一家名为“河粉86”或“河粉79”的餐馆，那可能代表这家餐馆的老板是在1986年或1979年从越南移民过来的。所以这是越南裔美国人文化中一种非常常见的命名惯例。这也是一种向这种新生活的开始致敬的方式。是的，就像在我们位于奥克兰的办公室周围，我们有一家“河粉84”，我很喜欢去。所以我的猜测是，84使它
one of those ones where it's indicative of a year. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. Like usually the numbers are signifying some sort of year. So you'll also see a lot of places named like Foss 75, specifically. And 75 is a really important number in Vietnamese American culture, because 1975 is the year of the fall of Saigon and the end of South Vietnam. So a lot of Vietnamese Americans actually commemorated
成为那些表明年份的餐馆之一。对，对，对，对，完全正确。通常这些数字都象征着某种年份。所以你也会看到很多以“河粉75”命名的餐馆，具体就是75。75在越南裔美国人文化中是一个非常重要的数字，因为1975年是西贡沦陷和南越灭亡的年份。因此，许多越南裔美国人实际上每年都会用一个叫做“黑色四月”（Black April）的活动来纪念它，
every year with something called Black April, which marks the day that Saigon fell on April 30th, 1975. Wow, I'd never heard of Black April. That's really fascinating. Yeah, it's celebrated mostly in like little Saigon's and stuff. So yeah, it was a big thing where I was growing up. So you might see a lot of 75s because there was a lot of immigration activity in 1975 because of the fall of Saigon. Yeah. So another restaurant number, you'll probably see a lot is FF 54. Yeah.
该活动标志着西贡在1975年4月30日沦陷的日子。哇，我从来没听说过“黑色四月”。那真的很迷人。是的，它主要在小西贡等地被庆祝。所以，是的，在我成长的地方这是一件大事。所以你可能会看到很多75，因为由于西贡的沦陷，1975年有大量的移民活动。是的。所以你可能会看到的另一个餐馆数字是“河粉54”。对。
So we talk about this. We talk about 54 in the piece. So this is when the creation of South Vietnam, the partitioning of the country. Yeah, exactly. So this is when Vietnam was split basically into North and South Vietnam. And this is actually a really big date in Vietnamese food culture as well, because, you know, when the country was split in two, there was this huge migration of people between North and South Vietnam because the North was now communist country, the South was
所以我们谈到了这个。我们在节目里谈到了54。也就是南越的建立、国家的分割。是的，完全正确。所以这就是越南基本上被分裂为南北越的时候。这实际上也是越南饮食文化中的一个重大日子，因为，你知道的，当国家被一分为二时，南北越之间发生了大规模的人口迁移，因为北方现在是共产主义国家，南方现在是
now anti-communist. So in the US, they called this operation passage to freedom, but essentially, it was this grace period where people were allowed to flee the North or the South before the border was officially sealed. So somewhere between 600,000 to a million North Vietnamese actually relocated to the south. And this is actually how my mom's family ended up in Saigon because they were part of this migration from the North to the south. Yeah. But this was important for like Vietnamese food culture specifically too because Fah is a dish that actually originated from North Vietnam. So for a long time, Fah wasn't actually something that was eaten very much in South Vietnam. Like, if you've ever been there, it's very, very hot
反共国家。所以在美国，他们称之为“自由通道行动”（Operation Passage to Freedom），但本质上，这是在边界正式封锁之前，允许人们逃离北方或南方的宽限期。因此，大约有60万到100万北越人实际上搬到了南方。这也是我妈妈的家人最终来到西贡的原因，因为他们是这次从北方到南方的移民潮的一部分。是的。但这对于越南饮食文化本身也很重要，因为河粉是一道起源于越南北方的菜肴。因此很长一段时间里，河粉其实并不是南越人经常吃的东西。就像，如果你去过那里，
in the East, you know, but it became really popular in the South because this huge influx of northerners that relocated to places like Saigon and Fah itself changed a lot after it was brought to South Vietnam because of the available ingredients like in South Vietnam. So originally it was pretty simple, but that's when we started putting like the herbs and the bean sprouts and just packing it with all this stuff. And so this kind of hybrid north-south version of fa is what was taken abroad when Vietnamese started immigrating to other parts of the world after the war. Oh, that's cool.
那里的天气非常非常热，你知道的，但它在南方变得非常受欢迎，是因为大量北方人搬到了西贡等地，而且河粉本身在被带到南越后，由于南越可用的食材而发生了很大变化。所以最初它相当简单，但就在那时我们开始加入草药、豆芽，并加入了所有这些配料。因此，这种南北结合版的河粉就是战后越南人开始向世界其他地方移民时带到海外的东西。哦，这太酷了。
Yeah, yeah. And so actually this tradition of naming restaurants to include a number in it, like an important date or something, is actually something that you mostly see in the older restaurants, like by people who are the first generation immigrants. So newer Vietnamese restaurants tend to be, you know, less likely to adhere to that, like,
对，对。所以实际上，这种在餐馆名字中加入数字（比如一个重要的日子什么的）的传统，其实主要是在老牌餐馆中才能看到，也就是第一代移民开的餐馆。所以较新的越南餐饮店往往，你知道的，不太愿意遵循那种
numbered name convention. So the stereotype about it not being like, quote, authentic, like a quote, authentic Vietnamese restaurant, kind of comes from somewhere just because the places with the numbers will be more old school, more traditional. Like I personally try to avoid anything with a pun on the word fa in it. You know, a restaurant called a fa, a nominal or something like that.
带数字命名的惯例。因此，关于它不像“所谓的正宗”越南餐馆的刻板印象，其实并非空穴来风，只是因为带数字的店会更老派、更传统。就像我个人会尽量避开任何名字里带有关于“河粉”的双关语的店。你知道的，比如一家叫“Pho-nomenal”（谐音 Phenomenal，意为“绝了”的河粉店）或者类似名字的餐馆。
Well, especially ones that imply that fa rhymes with show or that it's fa. Yes. Oh, yeah. That is my biggest pet thing. It's fa. It's not fa. Please, please, please.
嗯，尤其是那些暗示fa和show押韵或者读作fa的。对，哦，对，那是我最大的死穴。是fa，不是fa。求求你们了。
No. If you take anything from this code, fa. Say, do fa, you're best you can. Just remember fa. Yeah. Well, this is fascinating. I love the idea that you could drive through a neighborhood and just know a family's history from the names of the fa places.
不。如果你能从这段代码里记住什么，那就是fa。说吧，做fa，尽力而就行。只要记住fa。对。嗯，这太吸引人了。我喜欢这种想法：你可以开车穿过一个社区，仅凭fa场所的名字就知道一个家族的历史。
I mean, that's the coolest. Yeah. All right. Well, thank you, Vivian. Yeah, thank you. 99% of visible was produced this week by Vivian Lay and edited by Christopher Johnson, Mixed in Tech Production by Amida Ganatra, Music by our director of sound, Swan Rihau. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director, the rest
我的意思是，这太酷了。是的。好吧，谢谢你，维维安。是的，谢谢你。本周的《99%无形》由维维安·莱制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊编辑，阿米达·加纳特拉负责混音和技术制作，音乐由我们的声音总监斯旺·里豪创作。德兰妮·霍尔是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队的其他成员
of the team, includes Loshamadon, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Barube, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Long T-Buy, Diana Lai, and Grace Lai. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PiOrk on Instagram and Reddit too.
包括洛沙马顿、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。特别感谢龙T-博伊、黛安娜·莱和格蕾丝·莱。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我Roman Mars，或者在Instagram和Reddit上@节目99PiOrk。
You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every other past episode of 99Pi at 99Pi.org. Hi, this is Vivian's mom. Stitcher, Sears, XM. Good. Good. That's it. Yeah. Yeah.
你可以在99Pi.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99Pi过去的每一期节目。嗨，我是维维安的妈妈。Stitcher，Sears，XM。很好。很好。就这样。对。对。
Yeah. Okay. X, M. Good. That's it. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对。好的。X，M。很好。就这样。对。对。好的。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。